diese viralen Spaghetti Carbonara sind
mein erfolgreichstes Rezept ever über 15
Millionen Views und es war noch nie so
einfach sie zuzubereiten als erstes
guanchale auslassen schaut mal wie
wunderschön der in seinem eigenen fett
schwimmt als nächstes frische
italienische Nudeln kochen wir geben
unseren guanchale zur Seite aber lassen
das Fett in der Pfanne die Nudeln sind
fertig und ich gebe sie in die Pfanne
einfach zum Fett dazu das kühlt das Fett
ab denn ab jetzt darf es nicht mehr so
heiß zugehen jetzt kommt unsere Crema
Carbonara zum Einsatz jetzt noch etwas
Nudelwasser und rühren schaut euch diese
Soße einfach einmal an WoW und jetzt nur
noch anrichten erst die Pasta dann die
Soße und zum Abschluss der guanchale
ganz ohne Sahne wenn du jetzt Lust auf
diese Carbonara hast dann schau bei
pastapoesia.de vorbei der aktuelle Drop
ist leider schon ausverkauft aber wenn
du jetzt vorbestellst erhältst du diese
Carbonara met semanike mit Pesto und
meine persönliche lieblingspasta pakerie
mit Pomodoro und salsica